>> So we’re at Google [INDISTINCT] and now
here we have Paul Berry with us from Huffington
Post. And, Paul, I’d like you to tell us
a little bit about the print connecting integration
you did on Huffington Post and that you demoed
at your session yesterday.
>> PAUL BERRY: Great. So, it was--it’s something
that we’ve managed to put live in a lot
of traffic, and it’s getting great feedback
from users. And it’s--statistically, it’s
been a big hit; it’s kind off the chart
with the page views that it’s generating.
And the concept is that we always had these
slideshows that were really catchy and really
well done, and it was a perfect opportunity
to let users get involved and make it social
so that they could share it out to their activities
stream. They can invite their friends; they
can send it to Facebook, and the integration
with Friend Connect was really pretty straightforward
for us. It falls right into our model of making
sure that they can become Huff Post users
without ever signing up to Huff Post but just
logging in, you know. And so, we’re seeing
a lot of people everyday to sign in and create
accounts using Friend Connect and also take
their accounts that they had before as Huff
Post users and say, “How awesome, I can
connect that to my Friend Connect.” So,
it’s been really exciting and I think the
really key thing for us was a couple of pieces
of it was to show, one, on the users, how
are they voting so that they’re part of
that slideshow, you know. And it’s just
not the slideshow and the caption and the
title we chose as editors but, here’s the
community and you see them stacking up and
you see how they’re rating things. And then
more--even further, you know, that they can
rearrange the order and make their own top
five and send that out, so.
>> And so each user has their own URL for
their own slideshow that they can share with
their friends?
>> PAUL BERRY: Yeah, exactly. So that’s
the key is that whenever it will go out to
the world that when they’re sharing it,
they’re not just sharing the slideshow,
they’re sharing their version of the slideshow
and that process encourages the friends they
invited to also do theirs as well.
>> From a technical perspective, how did you
that? Are you using the Friend Connect [INDISTINCT]
50 pi or the [INDISTINCT] on the service side?
>> PAUL BERRY: So, actually, we’re using
both. And, it’s--we have a really flexible
CMS and with--it being largely done in PHP
on the front end side, it was really easy
and great with the rest API. And then, at
the same time, there’s some perfect places
to make those JS calls, and between that both
it’s like a scalable for us and efficient
and yet at the same time, really totally customized.
So it’s not like an extra added weird plug-in
on the side, it’s part of Huffington Post;
totally integrated, so…
>> That’s what I love in your--in the demo
you gave the other day. It’s like completely
integrated, so you’re in deep integration
in you site...
>> PAUL BERRY: Yeah.
>> Of the social layer.
>> PAUL BERRY: Yeah. So I think that’s what’s
really interesting is that for small publishers,
you guys are able to make it as easy as, “Hey,
you know, I can do a 5-minute thing.” But,
at the same time, for larger publishers, with
high traffic, we can do more, you know, and
pull off a crazy couple of weeks and special
thanks to Sergei Lazarin [ph] who pulled off
an incredible amount of code for this, and
integration. And, it was really rewarding
for him, too, as he went through the code
and worked through it. So, you know, it’s
kind of the early days of, of social for everyone
and, and for Friend Connect, and it’s so
clear that this has legs. So…
>> All right. Thanks very much, Paul. That’s
great.
>> PAUL BERRY: Yeah, cool.
>> Thank you.